the number B is five less than twice the
number C let me write that down so B is
equal to five less than twice the number
C so that's two times C minus five it's
five less than two times the number C
the product of B and C is 45 so I could
write that as B times C is equal to 45
which of the following pairs of
equations could be used to find the
values of B and C so let's see so this
one we have 45 is equal to BC 45 is
equal to BC so these are contenders this
one has 45 is he 45 C is equal to B well
that's like this is a different equation
if you divided both sides by C you would
have 45 is equal to B over C so we can
knock this one out this one has 45 C is
equal to B well once again 45 C equals B
we can knock that one out
this one has 45 is equal to BC so now we
can just focus on the first of these
equations so let's see B is equal to 2
minus 5 C no it should be 2 C minus 5 so
we can knock that one out B is equal to
2 C minus 5 well that's exactly what I
wrote here BC is equal to 45 that's
exactly what I wrote here wrote over
here so this is going to be our choice
and we can verify that this last one
isn't going to work B is equal to 2
times C plus 5 well if we distribute the
2 that's like saying that B is equal to
2c plus 10 which is clearly different
than this first equation that I wrote up
here so we can knock that out as well